now according Pakistan has sentenced a
former university lecturer to death for
blasphemy
Junaid javis was accused of making
social media posts insulting Islam when
he was a university lecturer in 2013
prosecution lawyers celebrated the
verdict by handing out sweets in the
courtroom before a trial took place in
Multan a city in central Pakistan Junaid
Hafiz lawyer denounced the decision
today the CN is totally condemned
condemned condemned liable and the
Sienese will be baseless and I am highly
disagree with the urgency and because I
closely observed the eye closely observe
the case okay I'm joined now by Chamuel
shams from DWS Asia desk Channel the
verdict has been called a gross
miscarriage of justice by rights groups
what other reactions have there been to
this well most Pakistani human rights
activists and organizations have
categorically condemned the decision
they say it's a travesty of justice
there was no fair trial for Hafeez he
was accused like six years ago
and he was put in prison he was in
solitary confinement there has not been
any fair trial so there are huge
question marks about the trial and the
organization's the liberal sections have
condemned it at the same time many
people in Pakistan because blasphemy is
a very sensitive issue here in Pakistan
and they kind of say that it was a good
decision because any class should be
punished
now Pakistan's taught a tough blasphemy
laws are controversial critics say there
used to actually target minorities and
liberal activists is that right it's
right because these are laws that were
introduced in the 1980s by an Islamist
military dictator have been used against
religious minorities the
time and again and also very secular
people in Pakistan so whenever you have
to settle a personal score or there are
certain various law flaws and in this
law so they are used against religious
minorities as well as secular Muslims so
they should be condemned
now have his lawyer says he wants to
appeal the court's ruling is there any
chance at all that the defendants death
sentence could be reversed well the
lawyers I believe will take it to the
Supreme Court where we hope there will
be a fair trial see blasphemy is
punishable to death in Pakistan so it is
very difficult even for the course as we
saw in the Christian woman a CFPB's case
that she spent ten years in prison on
false accusations of blasphemy blasphemy
and at the same time we see that mobster
tend to to punish the culprits
themselves the so-called culprits so it
is a very difficult situation we hope
that there will be a fair trial Supreme
Court and her fees will be allowed to to
present as lawyers will be presenting
their viewpoint and also another way
that half these could be pardoned by the
President of Pakistan it's rare but we
have to see but we have to be sure that
not many blasphemous have been punished
by the Supreme Court they have not been
executed
I mean Cheryl charms from DWS Asia death
thank you very much